Life’s all about give and take: Compromising
over takeout choices.
Trying for a different curfew.
Haggling at a market or over the price of
a car.
So whether or not you consider yourself a
businessperson, you’ve led a negotiation.
And the first step to any good negotiation
is preparation.
You don’t want to head blindly into important
decision-making.
Reverend H.K. Williams said it best: by failing
to prepare, you’re preparing to fail.
See, if we hadn’t done our research to
prepare, we would’ve accidentally attributed
that to Benjamin Franklin.
But you’re not going to fail.
Because you’re awesome at what you do.
And we’re awesome at we do.
So we’re here to help you prep by showing
you how to set goals, ask the right questions,
and think outside the box a bit.
I’m Evelyn from the Internets, and this
is Crash Course Business: Soft Skills.
[Intro Music Plays]
Before we get started, let’s clear up a
few things.
Lay some ground rules, if you will.
Negotiation involves two or more people -- and
we’ll focus on two here -- that have opposing
interests and something the other person
wants.
There’s no such thing as a single-party
negotiation.You can argue with yourself over
buying that pair of glitter Balenciaga boots
that Michelle Obama wore, but you’re not
negotiating.
You’re just indecisive. Probably irresponsible.
Let’s say two people are trying to split
100 lemons and they each want 60.
That’s a perfect setup for a negotiation,
because it /looks/ like there could be serious
conflict.
Maybe it won’t come to an all-out duel,
but who knows how serious these lemon people
are!
Jokes aside, though, negotiation is not
about ‘winning’ or doing better than someone
else.
Negotiation is about solving perceived conflict.
It’s playing nice with others and finding
collaborative solutions by communicating your
needs and interests.
You still advocate for yourself.
Don’t let someone just take your lemons
or pie you in the face with a lemon chess.
But you avoid hostility and find a solution
that helps the other person out.
So take that 100 lemon situation.
The two people might chat and figure out that
one wants 60 lemon rinds for their bakery,
and the other wants juice from 60 lemons
for their lemonade stand.
There’s not really a problem, and there’s
a solution where both people get what they
need.
Or if you want a clean kitchen but your roommate
has midterms, you might do more dishes this
week in exchange for a week off when you’re
swamped.
To make sure everyone walks away from a negotiation
with their needs met, you need to prepare.
And the first step in preparation is understanding
what your goal is.
Clear goal, full hearts, can’t lose.
I mean... we just talked about how negotiations
don’t really have a winner or loser.
But Friday Night Lights is just so good.
Think about exactly what’s important to
you, because your goal might not be as cut
and dry as you think.
Like, let’s say you’re moving to a new
city and need to commute to work.
Your goal probably isn’t to buy any car
as cheap as possible.
Because, uh, there’s some real junk on
Craigslist.
Your goal is to find transportation that
meets your needs in the most cost-effective
way.
That difference is subtle.
But it helps you focus on what matters.
And what matters is readiness, cost, and quality.
So a cheap car is one way of getting to your
ultimate goal: effective transportation.
If you only think about one limited goal,
like the price of a used car, you’ll end
up conducting a purely distributive negotiation.
And that can limit your solutions.
A distributive negotiation might involve haggling
with a car seller to drop the price by $150.
Just, like, going back and forth saying numbers.
Usually, you’ll have more options if you
focus on complex goals and conduct an integrative
negotiation.
Instead of bargaining over $150, integrative
negotiations let you get creative.
Maybe you let a seller charge $100 more for
a car, but only if they get the oil changed
and get you a Jiffy Lube coupon book.
Now, everyone’s happy.
The seller earns a bit more and you save time.
But in any negotiation, integrative or otherwise,
you’re going to need to make trade-offs.
Ideally, you’d reach your target goal, which
is the most you think you can get from a situation.
Something that meets all of your needs, with
a cherry on top.
So let’s say you’re arriving in this new
city soon.
And remember: your ultimate goal is cheap,
good, and readily available transportation.
Your target might be an immediately driveable
car for a really good price -- say, $4,200,
if the used cars you’re looking at average
around $4,600.
You should rank what’s important to you
in a definitive list, so you know what you
can concede and still meet your ultimate goal.
Are you willing to spend a bit more money
for a sooner pickup date?
Would you give up a couple of features, like
seat warmers, if it meant saving dough?
Must it really be a 1981 DeLorean DMC-12?
Knowing how much you’re willing to concede
depends on what alternatives you have.
Alternatives set your resistance point, or
the worst possible deal you’ll accept in
a negotiation.
So in the case of negotiating to buy a used
car, an alternative can be anything that
meets your ultimate goal of transportation,
like using the metro or taking an Uber everywhere.
If your alternative is terrible and you’ll
be walking to work in the snow, your resistance
point will be lower.
You really need a car, and your power to walk
away from a negotiation is limited.
And if your alternative is amazing, like a
free shuttle provided by your job in the freezing
cold winter months, your resistance point
will be higher.
If you can put up with the shuttle’s kind
of irregular schedule, you can take time to
make a deal for that Volkswagen bug of your
dreams.
Basically, alternatives give you more power,
or leverage, in a negotiation.
They give you time to consider your options,
keep you from giving up too much, and let
you walk away comfortably if you can’t beat
your alternatives.
And walking away is not a failure.
It might just mean the deal wasn’t meant
to be.
It wasn’t your time.
They weren’t ready for you.
Usually, you’ve got more leverage than you
might think, especially when you have a job
offer.
They want your talent and your skills for
a reason!
So never be afraid to negotiate your salary,
especially if you’re a woman or a person
of color.
Negotiating doesn’t make you aggressive.
It makes you smart.
To see how you’d prep for a salary negotiation,
let’s go to the Thought Bubble.
You’re a fresh graduate from a quirky community
college.
And you’ve got a job offer from a cool virtual
reality startup called Dreamatorium Enterprises.
They’ve got great health benefits, an awesome
office, and you’re excited to flex your
creative muscles.
Plus, you’ll have the chance to network
with some up-and-coming industry leaders.
But you’ve also got an offer from Hawthorne
Industries, a company in town that makes wet
wipes.
You’ve heard a few iffy things about Hawthorne’s
upper management, and the work isn’t as
exciting, but they’re offering you $5,000
more per year for your salary.
And in a place like Greendale, Colorado, that
can go a long way.
You really want the startup job, so you’re
thinking about giving up the extra pay.
But you’ve got more leverage than you think!
So prepare to negotiate.
Greendale’s not a booming tech town, so
applications for Dreamatorium haven’t exactly
been rolling in.
So they don’t have many alternative candidates,
which gives you a bit more power.
And you can point out that they won’t
need to pay for you to relocate.
They’ll save a lot on expensive training
and certification courses, since you already
know how to use specialized art software.
You used it to design your school’s flag
and create short films!
Plus, after doing industry research, you know
the salary they’re offering you is a bit
below average.
So they might have room to move up.
Your strengths look great, and you’ve also
thought about what you’re willing to give
up -- like 3 days vacation, a premium parking
spot, and the signing bonus they offered you.
So when you walk into that negotiation, you’re
ready to help them see the full benefits of
hiring you and get that salary bump.
Thanks, Thought Bubble!
To prepare for negotiation, you don’t just
need to have your goals figured out.
You need to flip the script and know your
enemy -- or, uh, your collaborator.
What are their goals, target, and the issues
they’re going to prioritize?
If you understand what they’re trying to
achieve, you may be able to move away from
distributive negotiations and create integrative
solutions that help you both win.
Maybe you own a burger restaurant and are
ordering from a new beef supplier who’s
trying to get their name out there.
So, in exchange for a 10% discount, you could
promote them at the food festival you’re
working next weekend.
Think about what questions you can ask to
help you identify their goals.
But… don’t be so blatantly obvious and
straight-up ask what their resistance point
is.
It’s a little tacky.
Instead, you could ask, “What other options
are you considering?” to get a handle on
their alternatives, and sort of extrapolate
from there.
Questions like, “Oh, so you just want the
lemon rinds?”, “How important is picking
up the car right away?”, or, “What are
you currently doing to market your beef?”
can help you figure out their priorities and
find ways to create value for everyone.
They’ll probably be asking you similar questions
too, so remember your goals and think about
how you’ll want to answer.
And if you can help it, it’s best to negotiate
in person.
Sometimes you can’t, but the hierarchy goes:
video calls, then phone calls, then emails.
Basically, the more personal, the better.
Remember emotional influence?
It’s easier to get a read on someone’s
intentions if you can get a feel for their
personality.
It’s easier for them to ignore your wants
and needs when you’re separated by a computer
screen.
That’s partially why cyberbullying is so
widespread.
Not okay, people.
Really, it all comes down to trust.
People are more willing to find solutions
if they trust that you’re looking out for
their interests as well.
When there’s no trust, it’s like a villain
negotiating with the hero in an action movie.
Everyone’s on edge, and no one’s thinking
of creative ways to get out of Nakatomi Plaza.
Sure... no matter what, your business negotiation
will probably be lower-stakes than that.
But with a bit of time and effort, you’ll
have built up a reputation as a master negotiator
who follows through and is willing to work
with people for win-win situations.
We’ve done all we can to prepare you to
prepare.
And if you take away nothing else, remember:
If you can help it, negotiation is about collaboration
and finding creative solutions so everyone
wins.
Clear goal, full hearts, can’t lose.
Goals can help you think of creative solutions
that target what you really want.
You may need to make concessions, but be aware
of what you can use as leverage.
Prepare ahead of time by thinking about the
other person’s needs and what questions
you will ask or be asked.
And next time, we’ll talk about how to jump
in and conduct a negotiation!
Crash Course Business is sponsored by Google and it’s made with the help of all these
nice people and Thought Cafe is our amazing
animation team.
Crash Course is a Complexly production.
If you wanna keep imagining the world complexly
with us, you can check out some of our other
channels like Mental Floss, where knowledge
junkies come to get their fix of trivia-tastic
information.
Also, if you’d like to keep Crash Course
free for everybody, forever, you can support
the series at Patreon; a crowdfunding platform
that allows you to support the content you
love.
Thank you to all of our patrons for making
Crash Course possible with their continued support.